I use stickers all the time was that an
improv on the day definitely
did you eat the stickers that are all
over it yeah it was gross of course it's
gross it's a sticker buying stickers all
the time dude we thought about that in
the in yes yes we did because you were
we we both were on the same page where
you're like uh I thought it was funny I
mean you were like that is the dumbest
thing I've ever heard we're never
establishing what does that mean Charlie
eats stickers all the time and we're
like yes I eat stickers all the time
that means that means you're a man who
looks at a sticker and goes I'm gonna
eat that yeah it's probably just like a
scratch of sniff sticker but yeah
so that additional line would have
brought it back for you if he was like
what are you talking about like you
scratch you sniff you taste you scratch
yourself it's like it's just scratch and
sniff yeah since when scratch them today
scratch the potatoes